[Musique]
en ce moment ma vie est compliquée à
hélices me force à fabriquer de la
drogue
enfin disons plutôt que si je la
fabrique pas une butte la journée je
fabrique de la frime mais parallèlement
à sa chute les villageois se
désintoxiquer si alex découvre que j'ai
des villageois je suis mort
tu te cacher mon identité c'est pourquoi
grâce à la magie du théâtre je deviens
quelqu'un d'autre avec ça adieu liorel
bonjou chant philippe bon je me sens
quand la voix
[Musique]
tu vois trop de faux guides baigneurs ça
trop malades allaient bien un nouveau -
deauville agi pour arrêter d'être mais
non mais je suis là et bien il fait des
cures de désintox et après on fait du
théâtre d'improvisation c'est super
sympa et théâtre ici je suis jean
philippe
j'ai fabriqué un remède contre le manque
maintenant je vais soigner le mental de
ces pauvres gens par la parole
bienvenue dans ce groupe de discussion
nous allons partager ensemble nos
souffrances
c'est le chemin vers la guérison un
premier témoignage
bonjour je m'appelle jean michel bonjour
ou jean-michel non non non le principe
c'est que tu restes et que tu partages
des problèmes avec le groupe ça va
t'aider
ok alors en fait moi avant j'étais
vendeur de catapultes
c'est un secteur hyper compétitif du
coup pour améliorer mes performances
j'ai pris d'un fou guînes je pensais
qu'à ça
j'avais plus l'esprit clair un jour j'ai
donné le bain un rocher gmail en puisant
la catapulte
j'ai tiré il est parti il a crié papa
merci jean michel quand as tu pris de
l'afro guînes pour la première fois
jamais j'ai jamais pris sam
je pensais qu'on pouvait juste parler
oui mais le principe c'est de parler de
son parcours pour arrêter la fois guide
c'est un groupe aux personnalités
hétérogènes
certains sont plus en retard que
d'autres du coup ça se passe comment
d'abord on raconte sa vie et ensuite
vous nous donnez la fraude insee salle
anono nous ici on est là pour arrêter la
frau guînes quoi dire là ils sont bêtes
sont vraiment béton vous savez dans la
vie
faire un faux pas ça arrive à tout le
monde ça n'est pas de votre faute
exact moi je pense que c'est surtout de
la faute de la personne qui fabrique
cette merde alors oui et non peut-être
que cette personne est en partie
responsable mais peut-être aussi qu'elle
a subi des pressions de son côté laporte
personnes et a abandonné bah oui tout
seul dans un château comme 5,3 pachot
pas rejoint du chauffage
tu te fous de moi y aurait là j'avais
peur je savais pas quoi faire mais moi
si j'avais peur je me suis retrouvé tout
seul dans un donjon pays krone et en
avait rien à [__] c'est pas vrai on
s'est quittés avec la russie détient
quiet way et tu t'es pas vous la
question que peut être une moc est aussi
gros si tu manques non toi tu mens toi
tu m'en rends toi de toi tu manques way
toit en toit
ok on va faire une petite pause ils me
forcent à fabriquer de la drogue je fais
des journées de 20 heures je suis épuisé
et puis l'a vendu clarisse quoi tu as
tellement malin qua non mais était
évidemment c'est horrible pour clarisse
ne m'emballent un bon faut que je rentre
château font sentir ça là si on veut me
faire griller tiens prends ça ça va
t'aider
salut je m'appelle geneviève je voulais
juste te dire que voilà j'ai trouvé ça
très mignon ce que vous a dit avec le
mestre du château vraiment c'était très
mignon
comment tu sais qu du château non pas
s'asseoir dossier d'ailleurs sa voix
c'est sa cause du vocabulaire les dents
et et encore j'en ai perdu 4 non moi je
me demandais si ça disait qu'on aille se
bat pour aller se balader tout des deux
homes
ouais ouais cool genre maintenant
ouais ouais bah c'est vrai je me rends
compte que j'étais un peu rentrer dedans
avec lui mais voilà moi dans mon village
l'espérance de vie 35 ans j'en ai 26
donc
je profite de la vie je fonce désolé
j'ai pas l'habitude avec les villageois
c'est batman je te mets une patate dans
les cônes on non on va pas faire ça
c'est pas cool ce tir échoue à l'orage
ce qui serait cool c'est qu'on est là où
on est dans l'air bon c'est juste des
petits visio a tranquillement ok
[Musique]
comme il est mignon ce petit couple
réalise qu'est ce que tu fais là j'ai
des espions c'est marrant je pensais que
tu serais chez toi tranquille en train
de contacter en or pour les des gens non
mais je tout fini ce matin là je me
balade sais qui tu es un connard fait
pas attention
je suis le seigneur du royaume des frogs
dont la légendaire devise lé dragon
dragons et mystères sont de mise c'était
pas d'un nénuphar à l'autre on a changé
ok tu donc le seigneur et la loi
m'accorde certains privilèges
[Musique]
je vais la droite cuisse et nantes a pas
l'aura de faire ça j'ai tellement le
droit de faire ça je vais la droite
n'est ce pas la droite puis c'est
comment je vais la droite puis s'arrête
introduit ces jeux-là droit de cuissage
la droite arrête indre accueillir l way
to play à droite cuisse et il peut la
droite qu il faut pas qu'ils la droite
cuisse il va la droite puisse élever la
droite cuisse et puis ça je peux pas
l'empêcher de dans le donjon de la
droite pourrait excuser moi personne me
demande à moi si j'ai envie d'être
droite puis si c'est la loi
ok je vais la droite cuisse est comme un
petit fou ça sonne et sexuelle
c'est le cas pour dimanche
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais pas ça durait ou
alors effectivement l'espion c'était moi
oui c'était moi parce qu'il se trouve
que j'ai une grosse addiction à l'afro
guînes est forcément vallat faut
financer ça se fait beaucoup ce genre de
choses balancer les gens comme ça ça
fait beaucoup et plus on est sympa plus
discrète donc pour moi c'était tout bon
quoi voilà donc effectivement je t'ai
l'espion à ce moment là
[Musique]